hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational we
are continuing with the match of round
end England versus IANA polishing and
it's quite the game and quite the match
so without further ado let's check it
out I think with the white pieces opens
with v4 and a young goes for Knight to
f6 with c4 and g6 forgot that the Kings
Indian defense and the dingos for f3 a
prepares prepares efore and nipple
replies with d5 controls the e4 square
now but being just transpose into into
the new groom fold weave captures
captures and E for just kicks the night
away and the difference is of course
there is no knight on c3 for you to
capture like in a like in regular groom
field so nice to be six
we have Knight to c3 and Bishop to g7 by
nipple with Bishop to e3 defending the
d4 pawn and now never just castles we
have Queen to d2 and Knight to c6 now
adding more attackers to the d4 pawn so
Dean castles Queen side and now already
you can see we have a castles of
opposite sides the nipple will attack on
the on the King side and the ding will
of course try and bust open the position
on the Kings side so Queen to d6 making
room for the rook to enter the game also
you want to develop your light square
bishop and now yeah it's a it's a very
common position in in top tier games
King to be one a knight to be five are
the most common moves here dingos for
Knights to b5 making it hard for for an
effort to trade Queens here because the
c7 pawn would be hanging so nepo has to
go back we have Queen to d7 and only now
pink the b1 we have a six and now there
is one a game in the database for Knight
to h3 was played but here dingos for
Knight to c3 and it is as of move 12
that we have a completely new game so
rook to b8 8 adding a fourth attacker to
the d4 pawn so ding defended by
advancing it with d5 attacking the
knight but now Queen back to e8 which
prevents Y from capturing due to the pin
and also prepares East 6 to it to attack
dings the extended center so Queen to c1
now the captures is again possible and
the 9th the a7 now nipple wants to ship
the night to b6 so if the in captures he
will open up the a file for his rook to
it to attack
with h4 being starts attacking on the
kingside and now tonight the b5 as
planned but of course being doesn't
capture just night GTE - adding another
defender to the night and II six now of
course you want to undermine that
extended center with h5 Dean continues
the attack on the Kings side and eek a
press on d5 very principled if your
opponent attacks and the King said you
want to counter-attack in the center
with H characters and g6 first F captors
and g6 you could capture with age or F
depends on how you were planning to
defend but the plus side for with about
capturing with the F point is that you
can later on if the bishop moves or
anything you can also defend the D H
bond with the queen or the rook or other
pieces along the seventh rank so first
thing removes one of the defenders of
the d5 pawn the ship captor Sun b6 so
now he can freely recapture on d5 we
have C captures and b6 and now Knight
captures and d5 and the material is now
equal where being has the semi open file
for his rookie and Nepos still has to
figure out how to go about his attack
so first Bishop to e6 now the rook can
also enter the game via the C file and
here it is actually very dangerous and
they post bishop pair is incredibly
strong if you're careless for example if
you try something like this you want to
trade off the bishops you immediately
lose but it's a very nice idea
you can even pause the video to try and
find how Dean losses here well while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting either of
the moves there are a lot of very strong
moves here like rook to see it is
obviously very strong but the the
finisher is Knight to a3 check and now
there really isn't much you can do here
for example if you go King to a1 then
just you continue with rush of
characters here with check King captures
or Queen captures if Queen captures then
you just lose the rook here and if King
captures then it just Quinta b5 with
check and now if you go to a 125 is the
game over and of course if you capture
the night then it's just check you have
to go here check you have to go here and
Quinta b3 is checkmate and on the other
hand if
tonight 2a3 you you actually capture
this night well then you again open up
the B file and now it's just Queen to b5
way to check and there's nothing you can
do here you're getting checkmated king c
to rook the c8 with check and the deaths
justice Knight c3 ro captures and c3
justa just a terrible position so you
have to be very careful it's almost the
bishop pair from hell but ding we'll try
everything to to deny it as the title
suggests
so Knight ETF for hunting wants to
eliminate one of the bishops not
allowing this diagonal to open up so
Bishop to f7 and now Bishop captures on
b5 it seems very dangerous to open up
the a file for the rook but leaving the
knight here to allow the knight some
some jumps here it would also be very
dangerous so captures here and a 3 and
if Nippo doesn't finish the game with
some sort of an attack the tripled beep
on will have well we'll just make it for
a terrible end game for him
so g5 by napal rook 8 the c8 first would
make more sense and then the game just
continues but Necco decided to go with
the g5 and this of course doesn't work
so if it was any other player except for
an F oh I would have said that this is a
blunder but as it is nepo you can never
tell and I I didn't catch any interviews
after the game so he ran mo actually
allows Knights to c7 biding to go for
the exchange and okay Queen to e5 you do
put pressure here and the Knight
captures an a8 it's not unheard of to
give up the exchange like this well that
have your Bishop prepare the rook the
Queen everything attacking the the King
on the Queen side but if you just
started with rook the CIT you would
still have all of that without
sacrificing the exchange so it is a bit
weird
and now ding of course closes this with
Knight to d5 not allowing any Queen to
e6 the Queen a to action and here it's
hard to find a move how to continue the
attack those those those bishops are
beautiful that's that's true but how do
you how do you you know make use of them
for example if rook captures captures
and Queen a1 check King escapes King c2
and if you continue checking just in d3
you're going to
maybe three checking e2 and the King
will be very safe on the Kings side
while you're still down the exchange and
you still have a tripled beep on so here
in empo played h6 he just improved his
position on the Kings side but now Queen
c3 now Dean says ok I'm up the exchange
let's trade Queens
nip of course declines and the dis not
really bothering him here as he cannot
reach the a to square so Queen B for
biding now going for Queen to e7 to
exchange Queens once again so King to h7
and now rook the d2 just adding another
defender here before the Queen actually
moves from the defense of the B to pawn
so look at the c8 now getting the rook
to turn open C file and the Queen to e7
again going for the the Queen trade and
the Queen is stuck guarding the bishop
on f7 so Queen to g6 and now just
grabbing a pawn Queen captures on b7 so
ding feels very confident as long as
this Knight is here this Bishop is doing
nothing and as long as this regards the
B to point this bishop also not not
doing all that much so Dean just grabs a
pawn we have looked the c6 now defending
this pawn twice and now Queen back to d7
we have looked the c5 now Dean wants to
trade with Queen to a5 if you if he
trades Queens is just game over so here
in a post-op side with a nice trick rook
c5 now of course if you trade character
scatters now you leave the night hanging
here so black would be okay after
capturing the night so after rook c5
ding just goes for night the e7 attacks
the Queen here we have Queen to f6 and
now Knight to f5 and it was in this
position I move 34 that Janna pony
should resign the game and ding wins
Game one of their match so here you
resign because well you don't have
anything the rook still guards this and
there's no way to do anything to try an
attack here and whatever you do ding
we'll just start trading off piece for
example if Bishop e6 things very happily
trades here everything and then it's
just two rooks against the rook and
Bishop with being being up upon and if
you don't do that there's not much you
can't even give up a second exchange to
try and keep the tension with the bishop
pair because again doing just trades
Queens captures captures and it's the
rooks against two bishops of course
completely winning for white so really
really a wild game and
really had some great ideas and that
Bishop pair was just amazing but instead
of just well I'm gonna go with that it's
a blunt with an apple never didn't
exactly want a la night to c7 so g5 is
okay but first you just go rook a c8
attack the Queen and after the Queen was
g5 and you continued the attack and it
looks at very very promising for black
so a tough break for nipple but there
are still three more games in the match
we'll see what happens and will he be
able to get back into the match so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Roland bowler
James Stern Christian Sprenger Kevin
Clarke and Henry's fragments for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
it's also Christian Springs birthday so
congrats oh I wish you happy birthday
have a good one and you know win many
many games and you know have some beer
if you enjoyed beer and yeah as usual
you can check through my previous videos
here thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the Magnus Invitational until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day